welcome to this video playing am I
estriol is car or a escape nice car
dropping back to him I like say kill
give from Russia his IPCA 2000 world
champion oh I pca no I'm I'm outing
myself to not exactly know what this is
I think there's some sums up I'm how to
doubt to call it some mum so group
identify the IPCA it's the sum the
physically disabled or something I'm not
sure something like that um okay I need
to look this up on so what did we have a
trump off scheme and I lost a bit of
time by thinking about what this
abbreviation really means yep okay this
is some simple move speeding up
development and I'm intending to do a to
go d 65 and the center not playing d5
with them with a very static position if
I hope is leading to join um through
slightly more slightly more interesting
position and
yeah did I just say leading to a
slightly more interesting position well
this is not really interesting okay but
it's also very safe for white now don't
want to go d5 really if I if I play that
if I this should play it rather quickly
because the Sun really might lead to a
super long game well why does marginally
better because of the better bishop
yeah most of the time on it will just
end in a draw but white is some an Invid
better yeah it was a bit annoying that I
played d6d 54 I needed to do this I
think yah hmm yeah maybe I can do this
and provoke him to take on g5 no I
cannot is it a big issue if I take and
not really come on and assistance is
just this is very little dad's really am
very dry
I don't really want to take and allow
him to take with the poem love it's
probably doesn't matter yeah it's still
fairly dead but
yeah unless I'm blundering addy five or
so hard to imagine what my what should
happen here okay so let's uh let's take
now yeah the funny thing is even if that
even if I am just trade down those four
pawns against or even lose this Paul
it's it's it's still a draw when I was
talking about let's say he keeps the
default polio and I give up all my pawns
and okay yeah okay this was a super ball
game what can I say but um it done it
was it was simply sometimes it just
happens you you cannot you get into this
you know and then he's playing this one
and how do you not play d 5 maybe you
can avoid it some some way but you'll be
aight really a rookie move to defend
this porn it's also not good and i don't
really see how to to make a sacrifice
all of it and then you into this
position not not sure that you can do i
mean it for for fighting purposes i
haven't could have made me play Bishop
g4 this is what maybe keep a bit more on
a bit more whoops yeah this is another
porn site just a new site yeah it just
happens to have some oops i wanted to
google them
Google the IP I I CPA emphasis ipca this
is the International physically disabled
chess association yeah this is father
physically disabled yeah ok so what draw
in this game not too too exciting thanks
for watching